يحرص عرفان الله على الحضور يوميا لفصله
الدراسي رغم اعاقته ورغم برد كابول القارس
[موسيقى]
الا تشعر بالبرد اشعر به كثيرا ومع ذلك
اتيت نعم
في هذا البرد القارس وعلى الارض وفي اوحال
يجلس هؤلاء الاطفال ليتعلموا محبه العلم
تعمي كما يقوله هؤلاء الاطفال
لا توجد في هذه المنطقه الواقعه في
الضواحي الشرقيه للعاصمه كابول مدرسه
حكوميه ولا اهليه ولهذا يضطر الاطفال
لتحمل هذه الصعاب للحصول على قدر من العلم
ناتي الى هنا للدراسه والتعلم فان التعليم
يفيدنا في مستقبلنا
الذي بدا هذا المشروع التعليميه يقول ان
الوضع الاقتصادي الصعبه لا يسمح له ولا
لاهالي المنطقه بتقديم خدمات تعليميه افضل
لهؤلاء الاطفال
الى 40 مقاط فن من مقاطعات البلد ويشاركني
20 من الشباب المتطوعين حتى تتعلم كل بنات
افغانستان وشبابها
هؤلاء الاطفال بنينه وبنات يواصلون
دراستهم من اجل بناء مستقبلهم وذلك على
الرغم من صعوبه الظروف التي يتعلمون فيها
حيث لا تقف يقي البرد في هذه الايام التي
تصل درجه البروده خلالها في كابول 20 درجه
تحت الصفر عبد الا نادر العربيه كابول